hi
so today i wanted to talk a little bit
about the gendered brain or blue versus
pink brains and it was mainly inspired
by this book from gina rippon called the
gendered brain and after reading this i
kind of rediscovered how much
controversy there still is around this
topic so that's why today i want to dive
a little bit deeper into this topic and
really find out what neuroscience can
actually say about brain differences
between the two genders and how much we
actually know and i do highly recommend
you to read the book by gina rippon
because i think it's one of the books
that really talks about some of the
problems in the field so the idea that
male brains and female brains are
different has been around before we even
could do proper brain studies
as a skilled practitioner of phrenology
i will now feel your brain
typical female structure
underdeveloped for arts and sciences was
stronger for religion and care of
children and in general it is actually a
question of causality so in neuroscience
we can of course see that brains of
females and males are different but this
is not only because these brains were
different from the beginning but also
because males and females live different
lives so in a gendered world it makes
sense that our brains are gendered
because the lives we lead are actually
reflected in our brains so for example
it has been shown that for people that
drive taxis that in their hippocampus
the vigil spatial area was a little bit
more developed or there was more gray
matter in this area than for
participants that didn't drive taxis and
this is just to show that differences in
brains will occur if we lead different
lives and in the end the whole
discussion of gender differences in the
brain is a little bit more nuanced in
the sense that we don't only want to
find differences we want to see if
they're causal from our birth so mostly
related to our genes or if they're more
created by our environment and this
question is actually a lot harder to
answer than you might think and it has
actually not been answered yet
so neurosexism or gender differences are
not new and still widely supported today
and the reason that neuroscience today
still finds gender differences so easily
or so prevalently is because of three
different reasons according to gina
rippon so first in neuroscience
differences are just more easily
published than finding no differences so
for example if your null hypothesis is
that female brains and male brains are
equal and you find that they are not
equal so you can reject your null
hypothesis with a p-value of 0.05 this
is such an way more interesting finding
than finding that the brains of males
and females are actually equal and the
second biggest problem was that early
brain imaging and even now today showed
images that for the general public seem
to be very easy to understand so for
example they showed images in
differences in fmri signal or in mris
structural matter in the brain between
two groups and as someone that is not
trained in mri or in neural imaging data
analysis these images seem quite easy to
interpret but if you actually look at
the details underlying these images you
will see that most of them have been
created with super complex mathematical
models or with highly evolved statistics
and it's actually quite hard to
interpret these images but yeah they
have been used by the general media as a
very easy way to show differences but
and the last big problem with research
in gender data is that usually their
conclusions are made in a causal sense
such that we have female brains does we
do this instead of considering that we
live in a gendered world and thus our
brains reflect this gendered world and
due to detangle actually this nature
from nurture debate is at the moment
kind of impossible with neuroscience
research because the only data we have
is correlational so anytime someone
makes any type of causal argument one
way or the other you actually cannot
really do this from the type of data we
have now so usually this is then an over
interpretation of the data so yeah these
are the three big problems that have
been occurring in neuroscience in
general and are also very prevalent in
the gendered data but i want to dive a
little bit deeper into the book because
her chapters and her titles and all the
research she presents is amazing so the
first chapter is called inside her
pretty little head the hunt begins and
the hunt here being the hunt for
differences and this chapter kind of
dives deep into the field we actually
started from so neuroscience originated
a little bit more from psychology and
philosophical debates because we didn't
really have the machinery beforehand to
really research gender differences so a
lot of the research that or research
that was done was a little bit more
speculative and a little bit more based
on what people saw in actual practice or
in behavioral data so i want to read a
quote from the book that was written by
gustaf le bond just to show you how yeah
awful actually some of the statesmans
were at that time charles marie gustaf
le bon was a leading french polymath
whose areas included anthropology
psychology sociology medicine invention
and physics so one of the things he said
was without a doubt there exists some
distinguished women very superior to the
average men but they are as exceptional
as the birth of any monstrosity as for
example of a gorilla with two heads
consequently we may neglect them
entirely so yeah the
existence of highly intelligent women
were as controversial as the existence
of gorillas with two heads and of course
this was written quite a while ago but
our origins do lie in some of the
fingers that had these very
dichotomizing beliefs and i think this
is quite important to realize that the
culture scientists come from is not
always unbiased and these kind of biases
can be quite prevalent even if the data
doesn't really support them so then gina
rippon dies a little bit into another
controversial topic which is now deemly
stated as neurotrash and this is mostly
very early on problems with neuroscience
as a field because something that a lot
of people forget is that neuroscience is
actually a really young field so a lot
of things that were published 10 20 or
30 years ago have already been shown to
not be true anymore or counter research
was proposed so i want to dive a little
bit into mri and fmri so mri is magnetic
resonance imaging and with mri you can
do an fmri sequence and the idea of fmri
sequence is that it's a proxy for neural
activity so it's worth to note what fmri
at the moment can tell us and what it
can actually not tell us and from that
you will have a way more informed
understanding of what neuroscience can
do at the moment versus what it cannot
do so functional magnetic resonance
imaging or functional fmri measures
brain activity by detecting changes with
blood flow thanos blood oxygenation
level dependent contrast techniques or
called bald and bolts reflects changes
in regional cerebral blood flow volume
and or oxygenation so it's an indirect
measure to
measure brain activity and the idea is
then that an increase in local neural
activity stimulates both higher energy
consumption and increased blood flow and
this already is quite hard to interpret
because what it exactly means when
someone has an increased blood flow or a
higher energy consumption in a certain
brain area is not entirely clear because
you can imagine for example that when
you just start using a certain brain
area like you're learning a new language
and you activate a brain area more or
there's more blood flow going to this
brain area or a higher oxygen
consumption maybe that means you're
actually a novice in this language or it
could mean that when you're an expert
you actually use this area more but
we've also seen that with experts
sometimes activities decrease in a
certain area so to really understand
what actually the fmri signal means is
quite subtle and different debates are
still going on about it yeah so i will
put a paper down below that discusses it
a little bit more but it's a quite a
nuanced argument whereas in popular
media it's usually just written like oh
this area of the brain is activated more
and but we cannot measure directly at
least with fmri neural brain activity so
this is already kind of bollocks right
and another big study or a big
controversy that i want to discuss a
little bit was the dead salmon study so
the dead salmon study was there was a
group that put a salmon into the fmri or
in the mri machine and afterwards they
saw there was actually some brain
activity in this dead salmon and this of
course is impossible so i will discuss a
little bit why did this happen so when
you do studies with fmri usually there's
a lot of information and the brain is
generally broken down into tiny sections
that are called foxels and these foxes
can be up to a hundred thousand for a
single study and usually when we want to
see if one voxels is activated we
compare them to another and then we do
statistics on every voxel to see if they
are activated or not so in general you
have over a thousand comparisons and
then you run into something that is
called the multi-comparison problem and
with a multi comparison problem this
means that usually when you do a lot of
tests some of them will come out as
positives or false positives even if
they are not truly positive so it will
show activity in a brain that is
actually dead and what you have to do
then is a multi-comparisons correction
and now in the field we're super aware
of this but actually when this study
came out or this was actually a poster
it was shown that 25 to 40 of the
studies during that time didn't correct
their fmri studies for this multiple
comparison and this is not to say that
all these studies were false but more to
show that the statistics needed for fmri
studies is quite delicate and even
experts in the fields sometimes use it
incorrectly and then if you want to show
differences between two genders using
fmri this can cause for a lot of strange
results if you don't use the correct
statistics so yeah i've already given
you a little bit of a feel of this
nature versus nurture in our book she
then gina and rip and then dives a
little bit deeper into this debate and
with mri studies what you would then
like to do is to go before the
nurture has actually taken place so you
would kind of in an optimal case
scenario measure baby brains that
haven't been exposed to the outside
world so a lot of studies that are done
in general research have been done on
babies but gina rippon kind of makes an
argument that a lot of these studies are
also overconfident in the conclusions
they show
because babies have one of the most
highly adaptable brains so even tiny
gender cues from our outside environment
could change their brains quite rapidly
so in general our brains are
rule-seeking systems generating
predictions based on the world in which
they are functioning in order to guide
us through that world so in order to
understand so this is again that
bayesian brain idea where we make
predictions and update our priors by the
information from the outside and given
the relentless gender bombardment from
social and cultural media that is
evident in the 21st century the
associated stereotypes are likely to
become much more frequently primed and
embedded in our understanding of the
social requirements so in general the
toys we surround us with the gender
stereotypes movies on how a girl or a
boy is supposed to behave and also
pinkification so pinkification is this
kind of insidious term that is used to
describe that everything girls use and
women use has to be pink so for example
if i want to use a hammer i can of
course not use a normal hammer i have to
use a pink hammer because i'm a woman
she gives a really funny example of this
stem barbie doll that was created to
stimulate the interest of girls to
become scientists but what could this
stem barbie doll create it was a pink
washing machine a pink rotating wardrobe
and a pink jewelry carousel and
i mean i don't have anything against
pink i think pink is a lovely color but
this does show that we divide our
genders in our world quite strictly even
from a really young age and i think you
can see this even better in for example
these gender reveal parties where even
before a baby is born we already place
them in their appropriate gender box
so then the tangling nature from nurture
is even impossible with very early
brains so even with baby brains it's
quite hard to really see what the
differences in the brains of boys and
girls mean if they are already exposed
to our gendered world and this is not to
say that nature doesn't play a big role
or that nurture doesn't play a big role
but it's just to say that with the data
we have we cannot really make conclusive
statements right now
so the last thing i kind of really
wanted to talk about and which is also
discussed in the book is
sex and science or gender in science
and i really want to dive into this
topic a little bit because some of the
professors and some psychologists that i
personally follow and really admire
actually make arguments that are very
similar to the one i'm gonna make soon
and that are actually kind of faulty in
the way that they are constructed so i
want to walk you through the argument
and kind of see what your opinion on it
is to see if you agree or disagree with
it but hopefully it will be an
interesting argument for you to follow
so something that i've heard a lot come
up lately is that in the west we are
moving away from gender norms our
society is becoming
more gender free in the sense that it
doesn't matter if you're a man or a
woman you will have the same choices in
your life and what we actually see is in
the west that there's actually a trend
for women to move away from stem field
choices so most women actually do not go
to the more hard science such as
mathematics physics or even neuroscience
and move more towards languages and
social sciences and the argument then
goes something like this that if women
have more freedom they actually go more
towards their natural setting in
towards social sciences or towards
language studies whereas if men have
more freedom which they always had a lot
of freedom i suppose but if men have
also the same equal amount of
opportunities they move more towards
stem type of
fields okay so with this argument it
starts from the notion that we are
moving towards a gender-free world or at
least a world where gender doesn't
matter as much in the choices we make
and i think already if you
know a little bit about
the world and where we live in you will
see that gender is actually still quite
prevalent otherwise we wouldn't have
gender revealed parties but gina rippon
actually says about this argument you
might think that it's only after years
of exposure to negative stereotypes of
women's intellectual capacities that
your ever helpful predictive brain might
pick up on the idea that on a whole
women don't do science or the idea that
those who do are not going to go far and
anyways you'll be very lonely and
isolated if you put yourself in sciency
situations sadly though fletching
versions of these kind of beliefs seem
to be established very early on in life
so these kind of beliefs that women are
actually not as good in science or that
we may not be as productive are actually
still very much ingrained in the core of
our society and then the theoretical
notion of what makes a good woman and
what makes a good scientist is actually
quite opposite so a good woman is for
example a little bit more quiet a little
bit sweeter a little bit less out there
as opposed to say whereas a good
scientist would be bold and brave and
very strong in his or her conclusions
right
and this kind of leads to this role in
congruity as they call it that if you
want to be a good woman by society
standards you cannot at the same time be
a good scientist and that's why usually
when women do get quite far in jobs that
are more considered male-dominated jobs
they are considered usually these women
are considered a little bit more tough
or a little bit more hardy or a little
bit cold even and these are kind of
characteristics we don't like to see in
our mothers right or in a women that
should raise our children so then the
argument could also be posed in a manner
that if we have more freedom in our
choices a lot of women move away from
choices that are better for us in an
intellectual sense and more towards the
role that we should supposed to be
taking according to culture and even i
see it a lot in women around me so i
think until the phd level at the moment
at least in my institute the male female
ratio is quite 50 50 but then when you
continue afterwards so towards the
postdoc and then professorships you
actually see the female researchers drop
out by large amounts and this is usually
because a lot of girls and women that i
know do want to become a mother at a
certain point and there is still this
assumption that a woman should take the
primary care role for the child and also
a bigger problem is that usually when
you get pregnant and afterwards given
give birth this is quite a big burden on
your body so usually there's a rest
period of about a year but the period
this takes place is usually between 30
and 35 and this is usually when a
scientist really has to establish him or
herself in the field so the only option
then for a woman is to or not become a
mother and become a really well-known
scientist or to drop science a little
bit and go more towards motherhood and i
think because science is such a
cutthroat field that at a certain point
there is really a bottleneck towards
certain jobs that this tiny difference
of one year between men and women can
really make a big difference
and i kind of want to end a little bit
on this last note and she also ended on
this in her book that nowadays in
science we we are moving a little bit
more to gender but also sex as more of a
spectrum so in 1993 there was this paper
written called the five sexes and five
sexes is actually that between male and
female there are more types of sexes
that could be considered but i also want
to link to this channel that i really
liked called jessie jenner for a little
bit more an in-depth discussion about
gender yeah because gender and sex and
sex being the biological side and gender
being more the social side is really
important and i think it's a topic we
kind of ignore a little bit in
neuroscience because it's so entwined
with our environment that we as
scientists usually don't really want to
burn ourselves on this topic but i do
recommend you to read the book the
gender brain if you want to know a
little bit more and have a really
nuanced perspective of this super
controversial topic and yeah i hope you
enjoyed the video and if you have any
recommendations of what i should read
next i would love to hear them so put
them down below and i also made a video
of my favorite neuron science books of
2021 so you can see them here and
otherwise see you next week bye